why'd you choose about damn time to play
what what was the reasoning behind
playing this for us this morning
well it's nominated at the Grammys for a
record and song of the year so
I want to show that off I'm proud of it
who you up against all of the greatest
biggest names
Beyonce Bad Bunny Adele
Kendrick Lamar you know you name it God
I genuinely feel like a winner already
and when I go to the Grammys and I go on
that carpet with this [ __ ] gown and
look [ __ ] amazing and I go on that
stage and I [ __ ] perform my [ __ ]
ass off and everybody loves the [ __ ] out
of it I'm like that's my trophy it
really is and to be nominated in this
goaded year I remember being like what
if they just completely Overlook my
album because Harry Adele Beyonce all of
these like big people uh Kendrick Lamar
dropped like what if they just Overlook
you know my album which could have
easily happened it's the sophomore Blues
they always say like your second album
doesn't get you know it kind of flops
and like I did the opposite of that you
know I had a number one in six Grammy
nominations like I'm winning I'm good
foreign